here we go the game has started gamer
started it's a King's Pawn opening and
copies with his King's Pawn as well
and which variation is Adventure going
to use here the Italian game is maybe
the most topical right now but he goes
for the Roy Lopez the Spanish opening
and Hans really wants to go solid he
does not want to lose this game Hans of
course for the standings so he plays the
Berlin defense and no end game we've
seen some quick draws in the bell in
defense but none of that of course
Evancho wants to fight and uh the game
takes us slower a slower turn right now
so um normally here black castles his
King
that's the typical move uh advantage of
just trying to keep as many pawns on the
board as possible and truck
he's got a bunch of choices here I like
the opening choice though from him what
do you guys think
yeah I mean again you've got to think a
little bit about experience
um evanchook much more experience the
hands so he probably wants to play a bit
of a longer positional game don't get
involved with too many tactics uh is the
general thing I'm thinking and he he's
played E4 E5 positions these type of
structures for so many years you might
think that that experience will will
help him uh Hans plays lots of different
openings
um his decision to go solid
um is is understandable and uh luckily
all the pieces are on the board still
and all the importance so it's it's
really just heating up at the moment
yeah and Ivanka do we have I don't know
if we have many games
in the days thousands yeah I would say
so there's like nine nine pages at least
okay and uh I can see Magnus Carlson is
the headliner ah and uh playing many
games in this particular variation and
after night this night move well top
person who's played it it's actually
invest in a part of in 2015 against
Alexander grishek I must say up until
this last night move from the black side
I'd had that position from against
Magnus against Carolina against Anna and
against swedler against uh just too many
players you play some good players yeah
I mean so I won't talk about the results
in those clashes they didn't go too well
for me from the black side of that
position but uh this white knight move
is just a flexible flexible move order
okay white does decide to Castle I think
White's night move was kind of aimed
towards preventing black from breaking
out in the center immediately so Hans
instead shaking his head there slightly
um maybe slightly
disappointed by his choice of move that
but he is asking a question of white
lights guide Bishop white select Square
Bishop could just take this Knight
um it does feel like maybe Hans has got
his move order mixed up because normally
you choose a different pawn move first
you push a pawn in the center for black
now we're actually going to transpose
into a known variation but black is
wasted a move with his a pawn normally
white kind of willingly takes this
Knight a bit earlier in the opening and
okay I'm expecting the black Central
Pawn to take this bishop
bit strange to to to play move and shake
your head immediately you know because
it's like you know it's a mistake so
it's like oh okay it happens that you
get your move order mixed up and but
little little Tempo losses can be very
important now and this seems like a
typical plan that that's been played
here but
that that little poor move um I don't
know could could bite hands in the
bottom yeah but I've I think I've had
this exact position except with uh
Black's a pawn back one square and it
was black to move and uh in that
position of course black doesn't really
want to push his Pawn in front of his
Rook which doesn't really do anything uh
black has far more productive moves
so it's a yeah um yeah Hans mixing up
his opening there slightly or at least I
mean he's he's not worse he hasn't made
any big mistakes but at least it's not
the most common still very solid isn't
it I mean uh I guess in the Berlin the
main advantage of black is the two
Bishops right so you've got slightly
inferior Pawn structure as black here
double pawns but you have the two
Bishops and we saw Magnus in the last
game beautifully using those two Bishops
so uh and there's no real other
weaknesses so is is still very early
days right and um I mean I I don't know
if we're gonna have any games in this I
mean I I be surprised if we had many
games with this A6 move but do we yeah
we we still do have games uh Fabiana
caruana has played this against Hikaru
Nakamura okay in the 2018. it was a win
for Fabiano and Maxine vashilograph is
also beaten Laurent resonate with the
white pieces here as has vishi Anand
against the Anish giri in 2019
so maybe Black's loss of kind of half a
Tempo isn't the most important I mean
while Hans retreating his Bishop
instantly and that Bishop was about to
get hit white is likely at some point to
step forward in the center with some
pawns so there's a very logical move by
Neiman and I'm expecting her either way
it's going to step forward immediately
or White's maybe going to bring his
Bishop out and maintain the tension a
bit longer it's a matter of taste here
for ventric he's got this as you
mentioned he's got the problem that
black is the one with the two Bishops
and although black bishops don't look
great right now opening the position up
like he's doing
does come with some long-term risk but
very logical by the center and it's got
good pedigree because this is exactly
how Vichy Anand handled the position
with the white pieces and uh in this
particular game black actually
challenged the Knight on C4 by playing
Knight B6
and this is I mean as our statsman was
was saying there's such an important
game either side wins this game they're
very very likely to qualify while more
so hands the ventric still got work to
do but a loss can can make them unlikely
to qualify so it's there's so much
riding on this one game here
um adding to the tension of it
um I mean White's got a lovely looking
Center here I mean it looks nice doesn't
it those pawns are controlling a lot of
squares you've got a lot of space I like
having the space advantages you know
when I'm playing personally it's easier
to play when you have more space to
maneuver your pieces behind again they
say chess is based on a battle and if
you if you uh you know have more ground
in a battle you've got more areas to
move your pieces to so hands now moving
out to a to attack that center of his
Knight trying to trying to gain some
squares I guess there yeah and uh he's
trying to provoke the center to commit
itself if white marches forward with the
pawn now Black's night would have an
ideal Outpost in the center of the board
so actually gaining space with the pawns
is not great instead of ventric very
quickly brings his Bishop out to
creating this pin black kicks that
bishop and we see a trade of pieces so
now it's two nights against two Bishops
which often favors the two Bishops but
right now white does have the center to
boot so uh kind of extra tension added
in this piece configuration and uh yeah
I guess black has some type of threat of
pinning himself uh creating this pin
it's very surprised he he gave up that
Bishop there David but maybe we don't
really have time to look at it but I
thought a van Chuck might have held on
to his Romanian Bishop but he plays move
here and you've got to restrict your
opponent's Bishops right and that's what
this last move does working out what
black wants to play and stopping Black
from playing that obvious move there
which which side would you guys take
Ivanka would you go white or black here
I think I would go for the black Pieces
Just because I like the bishop pair but
I think that White's doing okay as long
as this light Square Bishop is bad I
mean as long as it doesn't have a good
diagonal to point at I think it should
be okay but
I don't know I feel like
the momentum could easily slip away from
Evan joke about you David I mean I don't
have to ask yourself I know you're
you're a bishop lover yeah
Magnus both I guess really so you love
your Bishops a lot of top players do I
guess yeah but uh this exact type of
position it's maybe it's one of the
positions I like the Bishops the least
but I still would prefer them over the
nights the knights don't have anywhere
too nasty to jump into yet and the White
Queen comes out I was going to say
you've got to be careful where you put
the queen a typical tactic would be to
move the queen for example to the square
and maybe forget that after Bishop takes
Pawn suddenly this Knight is a bit loose
the pawn is overworked so if you capture
black wood much with an extra Pawn so
indeed uh ventric would see something
like that and he moves his Queen to a
square where it does protect the knight
from afar and it's a pin a short-term
pin but the queen just sidesteps very
solid stuff logical from both sides
valuation bar is heading in Black's
favor and Hans immediately pushes a pawn
very provocative to allow white to step
forward he does that to get the Queens
off the board and now we're in an end
game oh the Bishops are superior to the
knights we will find out
the black Mission will step back and uh
the white pawns might step forward
it's really imbalanced the pawn
structure here with black having doubled
pawns White having these beautiful Pawns
in the center but black does have the
potential of those Bishops so who would
you guys prefer then
I'll still say black okay how about you
guys uh Simon Ivanka I'm a bit more
positive with the Knights
um I mean uh because I just find them
really tricky and I like the center so I
I'm gonna I'm gonna take white here this
is the Eternal uh you know matter of
taste do you like like the nights or do
you like the Bishops it is I mean
Bishops really are stronger Knights so
you know but uh I'm not as strong as
David so I can I can go with the Knights
anyway it's a matter of test right I
mean viciana and loved his Knights
um
there were certain players who preferred
Knights but not many were there I mean
historically yeah but yeah
yeah I know I have to say I I like
Black's position I I think actually the
more I look at it the more I think that
he has quite a serious Advantage because
he has the capability to push those
pawns forward especially I'm thinking of
the ones on the left
and here you go that's looking very
quickly
and
very quick Decisions by hands but very
strong ones as well yeah now opening up
the position for the Bishops he's not
messing around I mean he he wants to get
that I mean when you've got a poor
majority so when you've got more Pawns
in your opponent on one side of the
board you should use that majority to
try and get passport and um I like
though what Chucky's done here trying to
at least close down the position you
don't allow blacks dark Square Bishop to
come in I'm surprised the valuation bar
so much enhanced his favor here it's
really like in a hands of position and
you know I I don't see it's a two-point
advantage to me but that is I suppose a
very nice passport there so uh yeah I
mean could some of the pieces be a
little bit loose for white
and okay
Chucky moves his King towards the center
but I mean how is white going to deal
with this protective passport and yeah I
understand you could put a knight in
front of it but
it looks rather defensive
it's all about that black bee porn right
now and uh okay Han's just making a
decision how to activate his pieces but
if the black B Pawn can't be controlled
in the long term it's just going to
March down and promote and the problem
for white okay Hans pushes this point
the problem is you want to blockade it
with a knight but as soon as you play
this move uh we'll see a rook trade and
the problem okay it has happened uh The
Rook will capture now and if White's
Rook goes away then this Pawn simply
drops off black wins upon and therefore
you have to capture with the white
knight but as soon as you step that way
with the white knight black will come
across and dominate the open file with
his Rook uh so that okay a truck is
actually just given up a pawn wow what
is this idea here he's given up after
Rook takes Rook he's given up his
Central Pawn
things will start to collapse is this
idea to activate his Rook attacking this
bishop but the bishop can just step back
still maintaining defense at this pawn
it looks like Hans is uh gonna do a
smash and grab just win a pawn for free
I'm worried for Chucky I mean I I I
really want to see Chucky qualify as I
said throughout because I just love
watching him when he's on you know in
gear but this is this has been a
brilliant game from hand so far he's
made it look easy you know hasn't he
just played very natural moves knows the
opening and he's gained a major
advantage now
um by by playing these natural moves
after we saw that peace and balance you
know the two Bishops against two knights
things Hans has just played it perfectly
you know he's stopped off Queens when
he's needed to and there you go he takes
pawn and uh he's looking very impressive
right now and I wanted to share with you
a tweet from takiwaki actually uh who
said they started playing chess with
their son in 2021 and he even baked me a
beautiful birthday cake my rating just
hit my birth year of 1980 never too old
to start the beautiful game I love chess
cakes yeah that looks so yummy have you
ever had a chess cake no but I've had a
lot of cake
[Laughter]
doesn't it I did once walk out of a shop
accidentally without paying for my cake
and I nearly got arrested the Norwegian
ginger cake thief
but yeah that looked gorgeous yeah she's
still some gingerbread though that's a
ginger gingerbread
I I I have been called similar before
but this this just it looks so good for
black now blacks are pouring up two
Bishops and it's whites nights whites
nights so there's David's calling
Superfluous nights where they can't get
in the game two connected past pawns you
know it's it's he's making it look so
smooth the Bishops can now come in with
a check it's this is horrendous for for
Chucky I thought you know if you're a
Chucky fan unfortunately but great play
from hands yeah he's uh he's made it
look easy as you guys said
um he did the same to Iranian a few
other players he's just very confident I
think it's the speed as well it
unsettles some of his opponents
Adventure has tried to keep Pace with
hands but maybe it was worth slowing
down a bit there were a few critical
moments earlier when those exchanges
those Bishop for Knight trades and
everything uh when all of those were
happening maybe a ventric should have
just uh
slowed down slightly and now it just
looks like push the pawns and you win
actually David you're right this is like
a rookie mistake that people make
especially on over the board tournaments
it's like you know your opponent plays
Super quickly and for some reason you
get carried away and you match the pace
and this is where mistakes happen yeah I
mean it's quite rare also for Chucky to
get out played you know because he's so
experienced but he has been matching as
you say hands of speed and that's not
really like Chucky you know he needed to
use that time a bit better I think uh to
to you know work out the problems in the
middle game I'm not really sure where
he's gone wrong I say that it's been
such a beautiful game that I don't know
what there's no one mistake and that
will make that's what makes the win even
more impressive that it's just been you
know when you can't identify a mistake
it's it's smooth yeah very smooth kind
of thing that Magnus Carson would very
often do to his opponents you know where
did your parent go wrong no blunders but
you win didn't Magna say that that was
his favorite type of victory yeah the
kind where the opponent's like you did I
did everything I could yeah yeah wrong
yeah yeah and maybe it's just those two
Bishops just came to life right I mean
as as the Berlin I'm gonna have to stop
oh did I just I'm gonna start playing
the Berlin it's got the reputation has
been one of the most boring openings
where the Queens come off and you grow
find a way but it's a blooming good
opening to Berlin isn't it David I mean
do you have you know your Carol your
Caro woman super Caro woman I remember
the Berlin from the world championship
match in 2016 though and that was uh
well I don't know if entertaining as
they were but it was tense yeah at
famously two thousand this is when
kramnik used it
um this is when it became popular
against Gary Kasparov to become a world
champion and I had a job there
um I was 10 pounds an hour showing
people to those those chairs in The
Stadium
10 pounds an hour was great in two
thousand yeah I was rolling in it and I
could watch the chess after I showed
them to the chairs and then they started
playing the Berlin like what the hell am
I doing here probably anywhere else it's
a good way to frustrate whites just to
make them it feels like banging your
head against the wall trying to break
the Berlin and
um I've had many kind of games when I've
heard black and my opponents have just
got frustrated overpressed and it's a
good counter-attacking opening and okay
hands mean well pushing Pawns the okay
really nice move retreating his Rook
I'll offering a rook trade that's a
brilliant because now his dark Square
Bishop is allowed to come in you know
he's breaking the pin and uh as Chucky
resigned Chucky has just resigned 17
minutes a smile and he looks a little
bit surprised actually Hans Neiman but
this is a fantastic result for the
American